من طول كرم ينضم الينا مراسلنا ليث جعار
ليث ماذا في احدث مظاهر عمليه الاقتحام
هذه ومذا ايضا في اخر حصيله للشهداء
[موسيقى]
والجرحى نعم يعني نبدا من اخر التطورات
وبيان الهلال الاحمر الفلسطين الذي تحدث
عن وصول طواقم الهلال لاربعه شهداء داخل
المخيم استشهدوا بفعل طائره مسيره اطلقت
نحوهم بشكل مباشر فيما لا يزال الاحتلال
يواصل عم حمله المداهمات والعمليه
العسكريه المتواصله في مخيم طول كرم حيث
شهد المخيم انفجارات واسعه ومتتاليه
واصوات اشتباكات لا تكد تهدا منذ ساعات
الليله وحتى هذه او ساعات الفجر عفوا وحتى
هذه اللحظه قوات الاحتلال تغلق المدينه
وتح حاصر احياء عده من المدينه هنا نرصد
في هذه الصوره في امتداد شارع السكه
والمتاخمة قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت هذه
البنايات وا وحاصرت الساكنين في غرفه
واحده ومن ثم بدات باعمال نشر القناصه على
كافه اسطح او كافه الغرف ايه المطله على
الطريق الرئيسي عدد من الاليات العسكريه
في هذه اللحظات وقبل قليل وصل الى هذه
المنطقه بالتزامن مع استمرار العمليه
العسكريه في كافه ارجاء مدينه طول كرم حيث
لا يزال الحصار الاسرائيلي على المستشفيات
مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي وايضا مستشفى
الاسراء متواصل منذ ساعات الفجر وحتى هذه
اللحظه طواقم الهلال الاحمر اكدت في
بيانها انها ان الاحتلال منعها من من
الخروج من داخل المخيم بعد الوصول الى
الاصابات اربعه
اصابات اعلن بعد ذلك عن استشهادهم بشكل
رسمي من قبل طواقم الهلال الاحمر لكن الان
اذا الان نرصد الجنود الذين لا يزالون
متواجدون في انحاء في هذه المنطقه وفي
انحاء متفرقه ايضا من محيط مدينه طول كرم
هنا شارع السكه حيث لا يزال جنود الاحتلال
متواجدون ب كثافه
وايعني هناك يعني على ما يبدو هناك اعتقال
قالات في هذه اللحظات بحسب ما يردنا ان
هناك عدد من الاعتقالات لربما سنحاول
التاكد من هذا هذه المعلومه لكن هناك
تواجد كبير في هذه الاليات العسكريه على
ما يبدو لعدد من المعتقلين من محيط وانحاء
متفرقه من مدينه طول كرم حيث لا يزال
الاحتلال يطبق الخناق على المخيم وعلى
انحاء متفرقه من المدينه في هذه الصوره
حيث اليات الاحتلال العسكريه لا تزال تجوب
شوارع المدينه شارع السكه محيط
الدوار الدوار شويكه وايضا محيط شارع
الحدادين محيط دوار ثابت ثابت وايضا
مستشفيات مدينه طول كرم هناك حصار واسع
يطبقه الاحتلال في هذه الاثناء الاثناء
على غرار العمليات السابقه والتي نفذها
الاحتلال في مخيم نور نور شمس تحديدا حيث
استمرت ل ما يزيد عن 40 ساعه الان هناك
تحرك جديد لاليات الاحتلال العسكريه التي
لا تزال متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه اكثر من
ست ساعات على هذه العمليه العسكريه ولا
يزال الاحتلال يدفع بالتعزيز العسكريه
وبجرافيك
لا تزال متواصله منذ ساعات الفجر وحتى هذا
هذه اللحظات المقاومه الفلسطينيه اكدت في
بيانها مرارا انها استهدفت اليات الاحتلال
العسكريه المتوغلة
عسكريه متواصله جيش الاحتلال اكد في بيانه
ان العمليه العسكريه ستستمر لربما لساعات
ولربما
لايام شكرا جزيلا لك ليث جعار كنت معنا من
طول كرم